[Music]
last week Metal Gear Solid Ground zeroes
players found that a mission within the
game may have alluded to the split
between Konami and Kojima long before it
happened
now as unpleasant as the split has in
the midle Gear Solid series is known for
having a bunch of really cool Easter
eggs and secrets here are a bunch of our
favorites there are a lot of ways to die
in the middle Gear Solid series but
perhaps one of the best is by not dying
at all after Solid Snake gets tortured
in Metal Gear Solid one that you find
yourself in a jail cell there are a few
different ways to get out of this
scenario but one involves a pack of
ketchup you're given to make Russians
taste better
you can ingest the ketchup or you can
lie down in a puddle of your own ketchup
your blood until the patrolling guard
stops by and freaks out then you simply
beat the crap out of him and make your
escape you can also fake your death in
Metal Gear Solid 3 if discovered you can
use a pill to fake your death and
bringing up a game over screen fooling
nearby enemies and causing them to move
along you can actually die if you stay
in this state too long though if you're
still smarting from konami z' treatment
of kojima why not head back to middle
Gear Solid Peace Walker and give the man
himself a hand at one point big boss is
tasked with finding a bunch of nukes in
a truck annoyingly though you have to
search through a whole lot of trucks one
such truck is a little bit special if
you correctly pick the one that features
Kojima's birthday as its number plate
you'll be treated with today or himself
huddling in a corner of the cargo space
he gives you a wave and heads back to
mother base via Fulton recovery where
you discover the multi-skilled Kojima is
actually a pretty useful engineer that
you can put to work
Kojima himself is also the subject of a
VIP extraction mission in ground zeroes
but his identity is not revealed until
you successfully complete it if there's
one thing we've learned about Big Boss
and Solid Snake over the course of Metal
Gear Solid it's that they have some
pretty crazy dreams in Metal Gear Solid
3 big
who is referred to as Naked Snake at
this time is tortured and thrown in jail
yep jail again at this point you can
save the game and reload your file to
trigger a codec scene with one of your
contacts paramedic
she'll chat to you about horror movies
and after snake falls asleep he dreams
and a minigame called guy savage
launches in the game a character battles
zombies with two hooked blades until
time runs out
and that's when snake wakes up at one
point in Metal Gear Solid 4 a much older
Solid Snake takes a short helicopter nap
and we're given a chance to play through
his dream this time it's the opening
sequence to the first Metal Gear Solid
game in its PlayStation 1 forum judging
by his reaction when he wakes up he
probably has this dream a lot which is
pretty weird here probably heard this
one before but I'd be seriously remiss
not to mention Psycho Mantis and his
memory card reading ways in one of
gaming's coolest moments the telekinetic
Psycho Mantis shows Nick just what he's
made of
he uses his powers to move objects with
his mind by activating the controller's
rumble feature after you place it on the
ground and he reads your memory or more
accurately your PlayStation 1 memory
card and comments on any Konami games
you happen to have save files for with
phrases like I can see that you enjoy
Konami games you enjoy role-playing
games and you like Castlevania don't you
when he makes an appearance in Metal
Gear Solid 4 he tries to do it all again
that has a lot of trouble this time
around since the PlayStation 3 sixaxis
controller didn't have a rumble feature
at the time of the game's release and he
has trouble reading your memory card
since the ps3 had moved to a harddrive
based storage system boss battles in
Metal Gear Solid II usually full of
Easter eggs and secrets snakes battle
with the engine Metal Gear Solid 3 and
the many ways you can choose to resolve
it is one of the best there are two
awesome additional ways to go about this
infamously long and difficult boss fight
which traditionally calls for you to
engage in a drawn-out sniper duel while
slowly crawling around a forest trying
to stay hidden you can save yourself the
by taking care of the end very early on
all much much much later on taking care
of him early involves aggressively
gunning down the very elderly sniper
when he first appears napping in a
wheelchair snake gets a bit upset about
it if you do this though conversely you
can kill him by getting into the bus
battle saving your game and either
waiting a few days or winding your
systems cut forward and coming back to
the game to see that the end has died of
old age snake isn't a big fan of killing
off the sniper master this way either
though snake likes to play by the books
there are of course way more secrets in
the middle of year style of series that
I haven't had time to mention so be sure
to let me know which one is your
favorite and I will catch you again next
week
[Music]
you